117 ch or la situation des réfugiés
soudanais au darfour on en parle peu
mais elle est loin de s'améliorer si
l'union africaine mènent des pourparlers
de paix au nigeria sur le terrain on
meurt encore de maladies de sous
nutrition ou de persécution dans les
camps de réfugiés
un million de personnes sont installés
sous des tentes à la frontière avec le
tchad dont l'armée épaulée par des
soldats français et tente de les
protéger mais aussi de les empêcher
d'entrer trop loin en territoire
tchadien
c'est le dossier de ce soir 3 il ici ils
ont dû lui l'armée française en
patrouille au tchad à la frontière avec
le soudan
en face c'est la région soudanaise du
darfour déchirée par la guerre civile
régulièrement les milices arabes
soudanaise s'infiltre au tchad pour
plier les villages frontaliers aux côtés
de l'armée tchadienne les français
tentent de maintenir un calme précaire
nous sommes en mesure par une par des
patrouilles et pour notre présent dans
la zone du wild fund arif de dissuader
toute action contre les réfugiés
et quand on les camps ainsi que contre
les wings 200000 sudan et se sont
réfugiés au tchad dans ce camp il tente
de recréer un semblant de vie ils ont
tous perdu des centaines de familles ont
été décimées en tentant d'échapper aux
milices soudanaises
le gouvernement nous a attaqué avec des
avions des chars et des hommes sur des
chameaux
il était 5 heures du matin on dormait
ils nous ont massacrés
nous étions assis en rond les arabes
sont arrivés et ils nous ont fait du mal
alors on est parti nous sommes arrivés
ici sans couverture sans nourriture sans
rien ils nous ont rien laissé
bien sûr que nous en voulons
gouvernement soudanais
c'est notre jeunesse qui a été tué ils
nous ont bombardés
on ne pourra jamais oublier ils nous ont
massacrés
elles nous ont forcés à partir les
réfugiés du darfour sont souvent
porteurs de maladies paludisme lettre
comme ce jeune garçon de 14 ans des
maladies qu'il faut détecter au plus
vite pour éviter la propagation parmi
ces malades environ 50 malades qui nous
ont été présentés on a trouvé six cas
d'élèves actifs beaucoup d'hommes sont
morts les femmes et les enfants sont
majoritaires dans ce corps et le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés fait de
l'éducation des plus jeunes une priorité
pour la plupart d'entre eux ils
n'allaient pas à l'école au soudan et en
plus ils ont perdu deux années entre la
première période de guerre puis la fuite
où ils n'ont pas été à l'école donc aux
on se retrouve avec une un grand nombre
d'enfants
et s'ils doivent rester longtemps ici on
doit faire l'effort nécessaire parce que
c'est peut-être leur chance de pouvoir
repartir chez eux plus tard avec un
minimum d'éducation ce qui n'aurait peut
être jamais eu autrement
la tâche est immense pour cette équipe
humanitaire resteras un médecin et deux
infirmières seulement à la tombée du
jour il abandonne le camp par mesure de
sécurité
dormir à une heure de piste de la le
climat à nouveau la france r c'est très
mauvais nous on aime cette fois là non
on supporte trois centres de soins de
santé au nouveau la frontière
la dernière fois que j'ai été il ya deux
semaines et en tenter dé la fusillade du
matin au soir
plus d'un million de déplacés sont
concentrés au soudan prêts à franchir la
frontière pour échapper au massacre
alors les français s'interpose au tchad
qui risque d'être déstabilisé par la
crise du darfour